[Music]
Wow what tepid applause thank you
hey my name is Chris Craig I work on
Android UI toolkit and I'm Chet Haase I
also work on the Android UI toolkit team
and today why don't we talk about
performance it's it's been a while since
we've had a performance talk so we
thought we should do it again because we
like talking about performance
for this year's performance talk we
wanted to make it a bit more use case
driven tell you a little bit about how
rendering works some of the changes that
we made some of the improvements around
performance but also go through some
steps of how you would actually find out
what jank is and how to fix it in your
applications so let's do that
UI performance Hey there you go so we
talked about frames for a second PS it's
a really good metric it's a it's a good
way for understanding what's going on in
your application but it's actually
better to think about the duration right
so it's not how many frames per second
you can hit honestly the display is
hitting 60 frames a second all the time
it's and then you need to sort of hit
the same number of frames for your
application in each second but it's
really better to think about the
duration that each frame is taking how
long is that frame taking to actually
draw because you're not going to fit
within that window if you're taking too
long to fit right so if you want to fix
the jank in your application if you want
to fix the stutters if when you're
flinging and scrolling that list there's
skipped frames in the middle and the
user is seeing this janky behavior
fixing that means fixing that frames
that are simply taking too long so also
it's good to think about consistency
it's great if you can you know have 60
frames per second most of the time but
then occasionally if you're dropping
several frames in a row that's not good
what you really want is consistent
behavior so chasing jank is all about
finding the places where you're dropping
those and making sure that you're fixing
the bottlenecks that are contributing to
those so let's talk about time let's
take a look at time
going forward from the left to the right
sorry from the left to the right and
take a look at what's happening in the
UI space so if you think about these
vertical refresh sinks you know on every
16 and 2/3 milliseconds typically on a
typical display we're getting a vsync
request right so this is the hardware
sort of posting the frame to the screen
that is when the user sees something so
divide that by 60 seconds divided by 60
16 point 2/3 I can go over the math
later if you need me to then if you map
frames on to that each of these frames
this is sort of these gray boxes are
what your application is doing in order
to post that information to the screen
right so ideally your frame would all
all of the stuff that needs to happen
for that frame would be within that 16
and 2/3 milliseconds I need to stop
saying that I'm going to say 16
milliseconds and you can interpret it
however you want so the beautiful icon
that I hand drew myself down at the
bottom of the screen that's the user
seeing things right so on each of those
vertical sync they are seeing whatever
the hardware buffer is posting to the
screen so they're going to see it you
know they're there they're there but if
there's a problem when you're rendering
if one of your frames takes too long
then the user is not going to see that
they're going to see exactly what they
saw in the previous frame because you
took too long in your application and
you skipped a frame so that's jank
that's the stutter that we need to try
to analyze and fix so let's take a
little step back and say okay how does
rendering actually happen in the UI
toolkit well there's the app perspective
so what's going on in your application
and then we'll take a look at what the
framework is actually doing on your
behalf so here's some simple code I keep
looking back and ok so you can see on
the screen back here here's some simple
codes we have this color things are
light gray right now and when the user
clicks in the middle of this custom view
are going to change the color we're
going to tell the view that it needs to
invalidate itself and then it's going to
redraw on it in the new color so user
clicks on the screen that signals that
sends an event into the on click method
we're going to change things around then
we're going to invalidate and then
invalidate is going to cause a later
call to
ondraw it's not a serial thing it
doesn't directly call ondraw but it
tells the system hey things need to be
redrawn and then a later call will
filter into the ondraw method and then
the ondraw will draw into the canvas and
that will eventually be posted to the
screen through all the operations that
the UI toolkit is doing on your behalf
so from the platform perspective what's
going on is several things in a row
first of all we on any given frame when
we get that vsync request we process
inputs so if the user is clicked if the
user is scrolling or flinging that's
where we get that information and do
something based on it if there's
animation if they had let go of that
scrolling list and it's now flinging and
just posting event so that it gets
updated as the list moves in space or as
views move around on the screen we
process those animation events we change
the properties that causes invalidation
so the thing is going to get redrawn
appropriately then if necessary we do
layout so something changed in your
application that changes things size or
location that's when we measure and
layout the things that need to be
changed again causing and validation and
redraws and then we actually do what we
call record draw so this is what we were
seeing on the previous slide in the
ondraw method this is where you turn
whatever you want to do into drawing
operations that we then receive and
store internally so you're going to say
well canvas you know draw this new color
so you're recording the commands that
should happen in order for us to then
draw the right thing under the hood and
then finally render and that's our stage
in this right so you do everything in
the first four steps in your code or for
standard views we're doing it and then
we handle the rendering and that's
basically the transformation of those
recorded draw calls into whatever we
need to do at the bottom layer I'll give
you a hint we turn it into OpenGL or GPU
commands that we then send to the GPU so
if we look at that in beautiful
brilliant colors which we're going to
use in some upcoming diagram we have
these five stages right so in any
particular frame the boring gray box
there it's actually broken down into
those different stages in our previous
example in that simple application code
we didn't have all of the stages because
there was
laya required all we were doing was
changing a color so we had the input of
the on click and then we had the record
draw of the canvas operation to draw in
the new color and then the rendering
operation that resulted from that and
it's typical yeah just like it says on
the slide in a typical application more
general frame then you're going to have
all of the steps in there so we may
process some input and some animation
and some layout and record and then
render and all of these things are
happening in a sequence right so this is
the order of operations in reality we
actually have two threads kicking in as
a lollipop
where we came out with a render thread
technology which we've talked about
before where we process all of the the
application space stuff going on those
first four steps in the application
space are on the UI thread and then we
have this separate thread that's
actually handling the rendering they
still happen in series in sequence
because the render thread doesn't know
what to render until you tell it but the
render thread can also do other stuff
asynchronously from the UI thread so we
can send over some of the atomic
animations that it can process in the
meantime but in general you do all this
stuff on the UI thread and then we think
that information to the render thread
and then the render said on that
separate thread will handle talking to
the GPU so in a well-behaved application
in a typical let's say this is a
scrolling or a flinging situation and
things are well-behaved in the
application Yin you draw relatively
quickly this is what things look like
again the beautiful eye icon at the
bottom the user sees the frames happen
bam bam bam bam everything's happening
within the 16 millisecond barrier but in
a typical janky situation all of a
sudden something took longer right so
here we see that the input command took
a lot longer so maybe when the user
clicked some expensive operation was
performed somebody made a web service
call or more typically you created or
you bound to view you did some expensive
operation that caused us to do a lot of
work pushed out the length of time that
you're spending doing all of that
recording of draw operations and then
the rendering operation necessarily
slipped into the next frame and the user
missed seeing that input because it
didn't hit the barrier so that's the
jank
and that we want to fix alright so let's
move over to talking about what do you
do you have problems in the application
you see now as Jen is described what can
happen when a frame takes too long let's
talk about the process that we call D
janking stepping through your
application and finding and fixing these
problems so the first step in dj''q in
your application is to run a release ish
build and so what I mean by that is make
sure that you're running with debugging
off if you're running with debugging on
art has to add in a bunch of different
checks and verification steps they can
add a little bit of time and skew your
results a little bit so we recommend
over writing that or testing an actual
release build so the second step is to
inspect your app visually as you're
scrolling through lists if you see any
jank occurring just visually detecting
that if you see an animation you know
definitely start with the most key
important parts of your app lots you
guys have a primary scrolling list great
place to start
if you happen to be one of the kind of
people that can't see Jake if you just
see oh well it looks fine to me
you can turn on profile GPU rendering
and that gives you all these bars at the
bottom which will tell you when you pass
that particular threshold and give you a
little hint as to what might be
happening based upon the color and
there's some documentation about that
online but the real next step after that
you've seen some jank you see oh yes
when these items come on screen or the
first time that I load this particular
part of the UI you figure out what the
interaction is you say okay what do I do
next well the next step is generally
systrace this trace is a tool that
exists in the sdk in the platform tools
directory you can also get it off of
github if you want the absolute freshest
version and so from here we're going to
we're going to do a very quick live look
through what is this trace actually
looks like so this is what you might see
when you pull up assist rates for the
first time so in this particular example
I was scrolling through a recycler view
in my app and I saw oh there's some
janky frames I can see some visual
stuttering and so I captured this this
trace over the duration of that time
and now a pull-up assist race and oh my
goodness there is a lot of information
here there is a lot of noise it is
really hard to see what should I be
looking at so first and foremost what
you can do is you can look here on the
left you can see okay well there is
kernels there's potentially other
processes you know what I'm going to do
I'm going to ignore everybody else for
now and I'm going to scroll down until
the top process the only thing that I
can see right now is my package Android
jank town and in fact you can even go
further than that you can you can look
on the left here this tells you in fact
individual threads that we care about
and this chat was talking about there
are two threads that matter here there's
the UI thread of my app and the render
thread so I'm going to scroll down
further until all that I can see at the
very top of the screen is mostly that
and so from a very high level even just
looking at this trace without knowing
much about it I can say okay the the
time in this trace goes from left to
right on the leftmost we have 0 seconds
going all the way further and if you
can't see the specific details don't
worry about it we'll go into some zoomed
in screenshots later but even from this
very high level view I can say oh well
I've got a lot of tiny little slivers
here these little pulses these are
frames ok great most of that looks
incredibly consistent looks really
smooth and it looks to be repeating
regularly however there are some big
visual standouts here and this is very
often what the janking is is looking for
these particular stands out frames and
investigating so if i zoom in here I can
start looking at exactly what's going
wrong in these frames and I can start
clicking around figuring out exactly
what the problem is and just so that you
can see that we're going to switch back
to slides and show you the screenshots
in particular so this is one of the
simple frames zoomed in pretty
significantly
that we saw earlier as those very
frequent and very regular pulses now
these were very nice they look like tiny
little slivers before but let's go ahead
and look at them to see what a baseline
is um so first of all one of the one of
the tricky things about systrace is
there's a lot of data here there's a lot
of things to click on but one of the
nice features is that
to these UI thread components click on
it since streets will do its best to try
and explain it to you so if you click on
this particular top of the UI thread
which means this is the topmost trace
section this is the biggest chunk that
represents the UI thread work if you
click on that at the bottom of the
systrace UI it'll say oh okay well this
is what choreographer is and in fact
here it'll even link you to the and the
documentation where it describes on D on
Android comm how choreographer works
similarly if I want to look down at draw
frame that's the render thread component
of the of the frame and if I click on it
I get a similar explanation there's lots
of this for all sorts of tracing
throughout systrace especially on the UI
or under thread where you might be most
interested okay so now that we know we
can click on things we can get a little
bit more information that way let's go
through exactly what does this frame
look like what's it doing so the very
first thing we see here is an animation
callback if you click on this it'll stay
animation or if you zoom in you can see
that and I'm just going to go through
these that way so this is the animation
exactly as Chet was talking about it
before and if we saw before we had a
whole lot of frames
I told you it was a recycler view so
there's one very common reason for a
recycler view to be animating and that's
flinging on just the the fling animation
itself execute recycler views actual
translate and inflate work as part of an
animation callback and then the other
stage that Chet talked about before is
record draw well this makes sense as
well but his recycler view is
invalidating sliding things around and
drawing okay we kind of get some context
for what it's doing and in fact if you
click on this part of the of the
animation which is inside animation this
is a recycler view scroll so recycle
every scroll is actually going really
really fast here and that's because
recycler view is doing very minimal work
in fact if we look at the amount of time
taken by this UI thread frame it's one
point two five milliseconds that's great
the whole frame finishes in in less than
six this is a great frame
congratulations now we look at a little
bit slower of a frame now this one's
actually not terrible but let's look at
how it differs from the previous one so
first of all we notice that there's a
measure pass in here
something in something in the hierarchy
requested layout and got remesh good to
know and another thing down here we see
upload bitmap so the first time that the
render thread sees a bitmap and needs to
display it it will be uploaded to the
GPU uploaded to OpenGL so that the GPU
can draw it really fast now that first
upload is a little expensive and we'll
talk about that a little bit more later
but really if we look at it well the UI
thread takes 4 milliseconds the entire
frame finishes in less than 13 this is
not a problem frame this is this is fine
but now let's look at the really bad
ones these are the ones that we saw from
very far away ok something is definitely
going on here but if you're new like
what what's going on how do I figure out
what's going on so actually if you click
on this part that says RV create view
it'll describe to you this is basically
your adapters callback for oncreateview
holder this means that recycler view
needs a new view and it's creating it
and in fact if you look directly below
that well a lot of the reason a lot of
the time that takes up this create view
portion is that it's inflating and
inflating especially with the complex
items in my recycler view can take a
while well that's unfortunate
the next part here on bind view holder
that takes about a millisecond and a
half not great but ok well what could I
do um you know this this UI thread frame
took about 20 seconds 20 milliseconds on
the UI thread and total to be about 27.4
not great we are definitely going to
jank that frame so this is actually this
process is one that you might go through
yourself but in this particular case we
realize well this is this is something
that we can help you out with in support
lib and this is a feature that we worked
in worked in for exactly that purpose so
let's go back and talk a little bit
about what recycler view does so
recycler view is the primary support lib
component for displaying a dynamic list
of content that needs to show views
dynamically that needs to scroll
infinitely potentially or display more
content than what is attached to the
view hierarchy so what do I mean well I
mean if you have these four items
partially visible in your recycler view
you start scrolling
and all that recyclerview needs to do is
handle these four particular items in
fact all that it has to do is offset
them very slightly and that's the amount
of work that we see and in fact if you
remember the very first RV scroll that
we highlighted it was tiny it was
trivial because the recyclerview did
very little but once we get to the edge
of this particular list well what
happens now we suddenly might see some
jank because this is a frame in which
something interesting happens for the
first time this list has five items in
it that means it can't get an item to be
recycled from previously that means this
message icon had to be inflated well so
that's the old way of recycler view
working so let's welcome let's go back
to a sort of simplified version of what
we saw in this trace let's say again
that this happened during fling we have
two frames that look totally fine they
they have short UI thread durations and
very reasonable render thread durations
finished before the deadline but then
suddenly you hit a big chunk of
animation and as we know in this
particular case that's because
recyclerview is doing its create and
bind work so we say something funny here
though which with render thread working
as it does the UI thread is totally idle
for the ten or so milliseconds in
advance of this new frame coming on well
it's not hard to predict as the fling is
going to continue I mean that's kind of
what animations do um in this create
work it actually could have fit right
there so this is exactly what we do in
recycler view prefetch we we started
looking ahead to new items that are
about to come on screen and basically
stealing work from them realizing oh no
that's going to do a lot of work let me
steal a little bit of that let me go
ahead and do that inflation early so
that we don't have to do that on demand
and this is what it looks like in
practice so this is a fist raised from
the exact same app all that I did was
update update the support live to get
this feature and suddenly we get an RV
prefetch event in systrace again click
on it it explains the prefetch feature
what it does um and we see wow that's 13
and 1/2 milliseconds that we pulled out
of the next frame we saved a huge amount
of time
work-stealing and now this is one great
example of something that the support
live has done but it's absolutely the
process that you can go through for
looking for problems in your your own
app support lib can't solve every
problem this way but let's talk about
prefetch a little bit more so there are
some caveats so what happens if the item
isn't actually needed what happens if we
prefetch an item and suddenly just
before that item is about to come on
screen the user decides to tap the
screen and stop the fling if the thing
is stopped if you don't end up needing
the item or if something else comes in
some last-minute arrival of new data you
might have done the work incorrectly and
really that's fine 99.9% of the time
prefetch is going to make the right
decision and you might waste a little
little bit of work in that particular
case what if there's no render thread
though if there's no render thread we
just don't try and prefetch to begin
with right now
so because render thread is on the vast
majority of devices you get this on most
devices for free by just using a recent
version of the support Lib but on older
devices this feature doesn't work so
availability this is actually introduced
so a while ago with support lived v25
but it's been getting better and
including with the most recent beta of
26 this feature is built into default
layout managers so if you just use a
recycler view horizontal/vertical
whatever with linear or staggered or
grid layout you just get this for free
this is just from updating to the newer
support light however if you have a
custom layout manager if you wanted to
do something completely custom or if you
wanted to subclass one of them in an
interesting way just be aware that you
may need to override this particular
method collect adjacent prefetch
positions and this is how you in your
custom layout manager can get the exact
same behavior and you can look at the
implementations of the other ones and
you can read more about this in just
wonderful post about recycler view
prefetch on medium but let's let's top
it let's step back a little bit and talk
about well what happens to jan well we
saw in this particular case that
recyclerview
having bursty workloads could cause jank
but let's talk about sort of stepping
back what has historically been the
problems for Android and jank so what
are the oldest ones that that we've
thought about is garbage collection
garbage collection historically had been
a lot of problem had been a significant
problem on Android but this has been
something that the the platform has been
improving steadily so GC for alloc was
essentially fixed in L with art I looked
at hundreds hundreds of traces I haven't
seen a blocking GC on any but the most
egregiously allocating apps GC is not a
huge problem but but then but even still
the runtime keeps improving runtime
keeps getting better at GCE lowering the
overhead of allocation OS thread
scheduling so this is a particularly
interesting one we're on very on older
versions of the kernel and on older
versions of Android sometimes the
platform would just make a bad decision
about when to schedule your application
this has been improving greatly on
especially in in and oh but it is
unfortunately kernel specific so that
means that it's not guaranteed to be in
every in Ouro device but definitely look
for newer devices if you're looking
specifically into thread scheduling if
you're trying to to make sure that your
work is running exactly when you want it
to rendering is an interesting warrant
when I work a whole lot of rendering um
rendering
specifically one of the things I
remember Chet and Ramon talking about
years ago has been view alpha if you
let's see if there's there's has
overlapping rendering there's set layer
type Hardware there's some other
callbacks somewhere that I need to
remember well what we try to improve
that so we started adding auto Hardware
layer and M get that for free and M plus
you can still use hardware layer to
avoid that problem but we've gotten even
further improvements in in improving the
worst case um bitmap uploads are another
one that I talked about earlier that had
that can cause a significant amount of
delay and first displaying your bitmap
but we added a new feature in in prepare
to draw on bitmaps that would allow
bitmap loading libraries to
asynchronously start that work early and
that's starting to be adopted by them
view recycling just as I said before
with another common cause that basically
support live has significantly improved
for you so added in twenty five more
improvements to come there and you can
and you can go back and watch the
recording of the art session from this
i/o if you want to learn more about what
art has been doing but I wanted to go
through all of those because I think
that tells you a lot about how the
platform has been improving and trying
to get the to the point where the only
sources of jank in your application are
ones that you can solve so let's talk a
little bit about some of the sources of
jank that might happen in an application
that might happen because of something
that's going wrong inside your app and
there are a lot of them but let's just
go really quickly so issues in
recyclerview we talked about issues with
recyclerview needing to inflate doing
that work at the last minute lazily
possibly causing 10 milliseconds or more
of work in a single frame but there's a
lot of a there's a lot of other subtle
issues in recycler view that can cause
unnecessary inflation and talk a little
bit more about that so bitmap painting
on the UI thread one of the most common
reasons for your draw callback to be
very long as because you're trying to
cache some work cache some content in a
bitmap but unfortunately drawing to a
software bitmap can take a lot of time
especially if it's anywhere near screen
size canvas calls there are a few canvas
calls namely draw path if you're
mutating your path frequently save
layers it can be somewhat expensive and
we've actually gone out of our way to
document some of these and I'll mention
this in coming up but let's go quickly
to an example of binder because this has
been one of the one of the favorite of
Investigation's of the Android
performance team in the past release has
been looking and fixing binder binder
problems so binder is the IPC mechanism
on Android if you want to talk to window
manager or if the view hierarchy thinks
you want to talk to window manager
you're probably going through binder if
you're talking to another person's
content provider if you're talking to
surface flinger
if you're talking across IPC you're
probably going through a binder and
binder has tracing
now unfortunately IPC is often very
expensive and truth be told it can be
really easy to accidentally add to your
application here's a particular
screenshot of a systrace that has a lot
of binder transactions going on during
recycler view scroll if you look at the
finder finder oh my goodness and they're
just running another callback on the UI
thread running lots of binder all of
these are pretty significant it's the 21
millisecond frame it's not doing any
inflation it's not doing anything that
should absolutely take that long it's
just binder overheads doing work that
they really shouldn't be doing on the UI
thread so tracing binder can help a
whole lot and that's on by default
in the newest versions of systrace what
to summarize there's a lot of reasons
and we've documented a whole lot of them
if you go to do android comm slash
vitals we have a lot of the material in
this presentation a lot of those samples
that i went to more more in more depth
with code examples so on and so forth on
this website and so now i'm going to
pass it back to chest he's going to talk
about maintaining performance in your
app I should point out to that that the
document site that Chris pointed to is
new it was just supposed to add yeah so
if you think you know the performance
docs on the site you might want to check
it out anyway much more detailed
in-depth info and the documentation team
was working really closely with the
engineers like Chris and other teams to
get the information that was really
accurate and and deep to help you with
this be janking so let's talk about how
you can find and fix and actually
maintain your own app performance it
boils down to sort of four steps you can
think of one is that you can gather
users to physics to actually figure out
where the problems are you can add your
own tracing it's important to note when
we're looking at all the sister aid
stuff that Chris Wood was showing that's
not a sampling profiler it's not a you
know we're not seeing like per method
calls that's not all the stuff that's
going on in your application those are
specific traces that we have
instrumented the framework and the
platform code with so the only thing
you're going to see in sis traits are
the traces that we've actually added to
the platform
because if we add a ton of traces then
it's going to slow down the application
so we add it in two places where it
really makes sense so you can actually
add your own tracing stuff we'll show
you how to do that you can add jank test
so maybe you actually need continuous
test so that you can tell when you when
you implement a change and you have a
new build of your application and your
performance goes down wouldn't it be
nice if you knew that instead of
depending on you know lower ratings on
Playstore because your users are the
first ones to see that maybe you could
actually have continuous tests that can
catch that for you and then finally use
the tools we went in depth on systrace
but it's worth thinking about some other
ones that should be a part of your
normal toolbox when you're developing so
one of the things I should point out in
looking at the user stats is this is a
screenshot of a dashboard that is now
it's actually sort of a theoretical
screenshots we don't actually give grey
boxes that would mean nothing so this is
from a talk that the play team gave on
Wednesday and talked about the different
metrics that they can provide on the
dashboard now so there are metrics that
are being calculated and stored on the
device that depending on whether the
user opts into it may be uploaded and
then can be information on your
dashboard for your application so you
can see what people are actually seeing
in the real world including jank sets so
how many of your frames are coming in
that's sort of a histogram of these
duration buckets so how many frames are
coming in at each level of that
histogram so you can get an idea not
just for how your application is doing
in general but also if you just updated
it and things got worse wouldn't that be
nice to know that information
that's being aggregated and and shown in
the play dashboard is actually coming
from internals that we have in the
platform that were injected in the N
release where we have this thing called
frame metrics and we have an API around
that as well and we compile this thing
at a very low level but you can listen
in on that you can implement this on
frame metrics available listener and get
the per frame callback data that says
okay
here's what the duration was for each of
these individuals
and if you think about if you've done
the GPU profile or the on screen
profiler we saw the screenshot earlier
all of that information is exactly the
durations that you get from the frame
metrics listener how long did input take
how long did the animation take how long
was the total duration of the frame so
you can get all of that information to
aggregate it yourself and then upload
and analyze to your heart's content we
simplified that a little bit in b-26 of
the support lib so the beta release
should have those bits now so instead of
listening per frame and getting the
duration and then needing to aggregate
them we aggregate them for you so you
can get this parse int array of duration
buckets basically a histogram and then
again you can compile aggregate this
stuff on the device and then upload it
to whatever server you choose to analyze
offline so the Playstore dashboard does
that for you for your overall
application but if you want to
instrument particular flows in your
application that are really sensitive or
important for you to get right then you
can choose to do that with the frame
metric stuff custom tracing so as I said
all of the traces that we saw in the
test rates example that Chris was
showing were the standard traces that we
have in the platform but you have the
ability to add your own traces in your
application so you should think about
doing this for some of the things that
you think might be more expensive where
you know you're you know triggering I
don't know layouts or whatever you want
to do it for for when you're binding
views or creating things that may be
expensive maybe you want to add a trace
there and sort of see what that time is
going to be and what it looks like in
systrace it's important to know that the
more you instrument the more time you're
going to spend actually outputting the
instrumentation information that's why
we don't have you know per method
instrumentation on one hand you don't
want too much information in systrace
because then the important information
gets lost but also you don't want to
actually skew your time by the
instrumentation calls that you're
actually making right so same thing is
true for your application so you should
think about you know if it's going to
take greater than a half a millisecond
then the overhead of the instrumentation
is going to be in the noise but it's
much it's much faster than that you
probably don't want to do that at least
not on any permanent
cases and performance tests it's always
good to have tests anyway wouldn't it be
nice if you actually knew when you were
triggering a performance problem this is
especially true for big apps and big
teams so if you have many developers
trucking code into a common code base
it's good to have an automated way of
detecting when problems come in if
they're not if you have developers
trucking code in and that are not as
familiar with your architecture or your
practices then you want to be able to
detect that earlier instead of catching
it the users level and you want to in
particular have tests around the areas
of your UI that are more important right
so if there's a common feed some you
know common ListView recyclerview
situation that people are going to be
going into all the time if that's where
everybody lands well create some
performance tests around that and make
sure that that code stays tight you can
gather the data on the user side on the
on the device side and app side and
frame metrics aggregator or you can also
do it on the host sides you can run
these command line tools dumps this gfx
info that will get all of that
information GFX info again this is the
same it's a different view into exactly
the same kind of duration data that I
was talking about earlier that you see
in GPU profiling that you see in frame
metrics aggregation and in particularly
you want to watch what's going on with
the different percentiles of your app if
you skip a frame occasionally no big
deal if occasionally you have a 700
millisecond frame drop that's probably a
big deal or if you have 10% of your
frames that are actually missing their
boundaries that's a big deal right so
just pay attention to a what your app is
doing and know and know what the
performance is like and try to get that
performance as good as you can but also
pay attention to what's changing over
time as you update that app make sure
that you're not losing performance as
you do it and then finally use the tool
so we talked about profile GPU rendering
something you can enable in developer
options very easily just sort of see
where where things are going what's
going on in the device when you you know
fling your recyclerview or whatever your
your common UI case is that green line
is important if you're going above the
grain line you missed
a millisecond boundary and you janked a
frame this one looks like particularly
janky frame I don't think they're making
any frame there so at least they're
consistent hmm they got that going for
them so you can do that on the device
that's this is more sort of at that
debugger and developer level to sort of
see where things are at again it's using
the same information that we compiled at
the lowest level and just putting it on
the screen for ease of use Android
studio just came out with some new
profiling tools in their latest release
that we're talking about that in some of
their talks this week so you can check
those out in the recordings on YouTube
in particular for this audience the CPU
monitor will give you information about
what's actually going on in all of these
method calls it gives you a good idea in
general about you know where the
performance is going on and it's going
in your app and also the GPU monitor
which is again another view into like
how fast you're rendering this stuff and
whether you're hitting the 16
milliseconds in fact I want to say in if
you're ever familiar with the previous
tools that used to be part of the SDK
the traits view that was built in to
monitor this is the same thing but with
a far better UI far more usable and
actually far more correct data as well
so far far more advisable so the way I
view is a different tool so we saw the
deep dive and systrace and especially
when you first see situates you're like
I never want to see that tool again
there's just so much information there
and you're not quite sure what to do
with the information that is the tool
that has all of the information it just
takes a little bit of getting used to in
using it to see how it works and how you
can define the information you need and
add the custom traces that you want I
think an easier way to get into it is
you can dip in slowly by using them much
easier to use higher level view of
what's going on with the Android studio
tools and then if there's a particular
source of jank that you're trying to
chase know that systrace is a
fine-grained tool that's going to help
you chase that at a much deeper level
system-wide and finally not on topic but
for this crowd that's interested in
performance you may want to try out a
developer option that will enable this
alternative render that's not on by
default but you can see how your
application behaves with this for
possible future possibilities
so it's the skia render you can go into
developer options and enable that and
just make sure that there's not an issue
there if there is it be lovely to hear
about it that's why we're mentioning it
today there are some resources that we
mentioned I will bring them up again
again check out the vitals page on da
Android comm in particular they have a
jank section called Lulu rendering is
and there are some important i/o
sessions to check out on YouTube they're
probably posted already Tim Marie gave a
great overview about systrace and system
performance in general so Android
performance overview the art talk talked
about performance and memory
improvements they did some pretty
amazing stuff on both the runtime side
runtime improvements as well as the GC
side so now they have concurrent garbage
collection there's almost no pauses
anymore until they need to take a full
GC eventually and they can compact in
the foreground you get a minimal size
keep you get much faster allocations as
well as collections so the details for
all of that suffer and the art talk and
then finally there's a talk by the
plague folks called no one likes
crashing or janky apps which is true and
that's where they talked about the dash
board and some of the other facilities
that they're providing for developers
and that is the talk alright
[Applause]
[Music]